[Musik]
[Applaus]
gut 150 euro gekostet und jetzt alle
gemeinsam dieses videos nicht
geschwommen sein ich habe ihnen von
meinem eigenen geld gekauft auch wenn
ich mich nicht an den preis erinnern
kann habe das ist von meinem bezahlt das
kostet er ein tschechisches herrn 82
euro und 22 glossybox selber kostet der
99 euro kann man gar nicht sein
details losbox farbe ein wirklich sehr
gut gelungene adventskalender die
produkte sind sehr gut gemischt von
allem etwas dabei und jeder sollte was
mit den allermeisten produkten anfangen
können zudem sind wirklich hochwertige
und bekannte produkte und marken dabei
formal mag man meinen karten ist aber
auch wieder so als ob wir absichtlich
machen würden
doch in meinem bett gehen bei timo nicht
da ist eigentlich kann ich meinen
rechtmäßigen platz einnehmen als sie
hier ist jetzt mal die schlechteste
bewertung von ok ich finde es sehr
schade dass so viele mini größen
enthalten sind auch kamen mit produkten
aus vorher von dem jersey boxen bekannt
vor
die farben der lippen produkte für mich
nicht ich muss sagen ich schon
enttäuscht vom inhalt kelly schon länger
zusammen getestet
dann geht's jetzt los ich bin auch ich
weiß auch also ich weiß es nicht
erwarten aber irgendwie auch nicht dazu
gespannt was drin ist überhaupt nicht
eingelöst
okay aber du wirst trotzdem duschen das
gesagte wird jedes zweite produkt
wahrscheinlich mit nach hause nehmen
wollen kann man muss auch beim gehen
ihren koffer kontrollieren schmuggel ich
was ein mann also wenn da wirklich nur
kleine produkte
dabei sind es gar nicht so unrealistisch
so many beautiful thing is in the world
is not die verpackung sehr schön
wir sind schon ausgerastet ja wirklich
schön aus jetzt tücher nummer eins muss
man erst mal finden manche sind
ausgeschrieben manche zahlen steht als
anderswo
bist du auch eine mischung von so karton
haare und ein bisschen katzen durchfall
und mein gott sucht jetzt mal die 1 darf
ich keine einer wendländer ohne leine 1
habt ihr denn so was schon mal gehört
sein die so sind 47 m 11 20
ich weiß dass ich wirklich gründen
werden da ist keine ich schaue mir da
ist keine die 17
sie lacht mich noch aus als möchte und
welche durch die viertel 24
ich würde sagen wir kaum ein gast ist
dass du auf jeden fall die nummer eins
hat sich nach viel papier an
also das ist das erste produkt es ist
sos ampullen des beauty rescue wer wird
gestärkt feuchtigkeitsspendend und
uneben mäßigkeit mein ausgeglichen
weiter geht's mit türchen nummer zwei
und dahinter verbirgt sich die julia
kosmetik meets glossybox wo es mit
glossybox collection vegane eine
baustelle
auch das dunkle oder helle also ich muss
sagen ich bin begeistert gerade davon
[Musik]
sind ja auch gut
weiter geht's mit türchen nummer drei
[Musik]
und koffer packe herper auf rabatte
das quietschen also ich würde sagen dass
war ich auf jeden fall auch mal zur
weihnachtszeit wenn es dann los das
immer highlighting schimmer michael
beauty sowieso eine gold fahrers auch
eher was für deinen hauttyp so ein
bisschen dunkler für die nachwelt ist ab
sofort immer benutzen diese fähigkeit
bei dem finde ich das lässt sich das ein
bisschen zu schlecht ja warum weil wir
unser gesicht budak haben für die kamera
und man soll ja schließlich nicht auf
puder machen deswegen diese highlight
sie wirklich groß
das ist für die kameras nach einem
lipliner aus ich muss jetzt mal kurz
sagen wie sehr es mich abfahrt plastik
von stiften drunter zu machen
was haben wir hier während kelly wichtig
machen wir weiter mit der nummer 6 oder
es ist die nummer 9 umgedreht wir wissen
es nicht aber wir machen
wir haben in küchen nummer sechs unserer
nikolaus küchen ist ein glossybox
monströser 3 in einsplus preis und
protect der lippen sieht sehr gut aus
ich habe meine oma freigelassen anderen
lippen erlebnis vielleicht haben wir
vier lippen an den rippen produkte
probieren könnte es richtig gut
basically haben wir noch mehr
[Gelächter]
also wir müssen es eigentlich sofort
frei macht frau kelly ich habe ihn heute
ein ganz tolles neues produkt
mitgebracht aus unserer linie und zwar
hier den meister kann ich mal ganz ihrer
hand haben
thank you very much so dass einfach
morgens auftragen an sondern das abends
sehr und bin und wo das sehr erfrischend
witzig sehr erfrischenden highlight
falls ihr warum ein mitgehen glossybox
ist ging care produkten habt dann
schreibt keine panik und haben einmal
sieben kelly die 740 groß suchmaske geht
immer wirst du augen patches sich alle
für unter die augen denn die
adventskalender assistenten befinden
sich hinter dem türchen nummer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass du dir nur eine lippe an gewalt
wirklich sehr schön ja es passt was
musst du ausprobieren mit zaz ist
wirklich an sagen ja so schokolade
nascht sich aber auch aus dem teambus
falls nicht wird sich die marke von
rihanna machen sie das noch meine mütter
aus flaschen trinken wenn die
lippenstifte haben ja die ist eigentlich
meine lieblings fahren passt perfekt zur
box so das ist ein sehr weiches ghani
mit einem sehr weichen material
okay die nummer 10
gehen wir nicht ausfragen den kennen wir
alle ganz tolle branche ist technik für
make-up sehr schön ja wirklich sowie ein
türchen hüther ab korrekter weltkrieg
primer glaube ich wie eine marke bixente
rouge wo ist aber sehr geschmeidig lässt
sind glossy finnischen nicht so man
aber dann steht heute raum hat aber
wieder trainieren und vielleicht ganz
trocken dann wird es dann so markt
nummer 12 markt masken heavy soll dessen
shampoo seine und meine pilot kann man
auch alle instrumente also was macht es
eine macht ist keine eine eine maske für
kopfhaut und schatten schaffen
gleichzeitig schon relativ kleine
abenteuer
ja aber es soll man wahrscheinlich dann
auch noch einmal die woche oder so
werden überhaupt benutzen das special
treat mensch dann wird aus dem 20
die zwei schon wieder so ein kleines das
heißt doch gar nicht kelly auf die größe
kommt sie nicht
mir ist alles kleiner höhere collagen
oder gehen hier wurde fiel unter die
augen jahres oder augen schreiben und
reden ja okay weil ich habe keine die
vierte ist bestimmt
susanne klein wander blut und volume
entlang
mascara heimat
nein weißt du nicht mehr im prime cup
ist im heim mal klappt oder mile high
club mal nein es ist wenn man im
flugzeug geschlechtsverkehr hat auf der
toilette
es ist irgendwie ein komisches wimpern
maske vom gesicht
oh mein gott ist wohl der unterschied
kann mir so forschen dass leute die sich
nicht schminken so dieses video koopmann
soll
ich sehe keinen unterschied keinen
unterschied und was macht einen
unterschied wenn wir ein richtig krass
produkte erkannt haben dann schreibt
über den kommentar des kleines feines
damaskus 1 1
google zudem flogen carey probier doch
mal aus und ich sag dir wie deine
leistung ist irgendwie ein gott bleibt
nur der sieht aus als könnte man leute
damit umbringen als würde man sie auch
machen da kommt eine kleine nadel
draußen
[Musik]
über unsere leistung vor einer irgendwie
gemalte wimpern zumal sie auch in
anderen ost und freihändig ohne tisch ok
du sagst es schön ist schön erst schön
du sagst kelly kelly der länder sieht
super aus
kelly du hast einen tollen eyeliner
gemalt
ja ja ja wie findest du die farben für
kriege eigentlich ich habe hier in
dieser historischen bessere alternative
und er läuft auch ausgelöste kann nicht
mal ganz gut ausprobieren weil er neu
ich glaube ich in dir sitzen und das hab
ich nicht unendlich süß aufs konto clips
patente
project davon habe ich schon mal gehört
dieser anzug ist wirklich nur eine probe
also die sonne kann ich bei douglas
umsonst ich wollte mir die immer
flughafen holen da war irgendwie ist mir
danach wird zu teuer
das sind sie an die häufigsten projekten
[Gelächter]
aber auch so lange
[Musik]
der kalender von der flasche der augen
das kann so schnell schmuddelig was ein
mann nach hause
3 ich bin nicht ich diesen sport ist ein
bisschen satt muss ich sagen kann diesen
geruch nicht mehr haben
[Musik]
little paint oder sehr dunkle farben
aber alles muss ich dann aber gut es ist
ja auch weihnachtszeit muss man dazu
sagen
das heißt die farbe die oberlippe
schöner tun
sehr schön bei 20 jahren das von der
aqua angeht ich denke sich frenkel maske
ganz toll ich habe nämlich schon ein
paar will ihn jetzt schon ein bisschen
älter winkel für sofortige ländern von
mimikfalten so sich wirklich jedes mal
wenn ich getroffen habe
tony kelly was ist ein falscher ton ach
so kann man nach dem schminken als
feuchtigkeit beim abschminken seine
linien total happy dass alle 23 ist die
mutige wir eigentlich fürs komplette
review gewünscht dass mit yahoo
das ist eine tolle abwechslung dazu zum
ende und passend farblich zum rest
incredible thing
ich beschreibe ihnen ganz kurz was ich
hier sehr lieben hat sich gerade den dem
cas eine schöne farbe ja hammer tolle
fahrer ist ding nur das einzige problem
ist ja der verschluss oben seid kranke
muss man wird zur 24 und aus dem erp die
adventskalender wissen wir dass die
messlatte für das 24 türchen
hoch also wenn ihr das hier euch mal
anschaut ist die krone was ist im 24
diese natürlichen von glossybox träne
als kakophonie kennst du ein könig
[Musik]
oli schöne farben berlin gefällt mir
ganz besonders nicht mag 24 karat gold
company fans das ist wirklich toll war
ja normal
das ist ja die sind nicht von cremig
made in peers volksrepublik china
okay sie wird schon mal wenn du bist
verkauf das ist schon der heirat vans
kalender nur das typische na also man
kann auf jeden fall sagen wenn man wenig
zahlen möchte mehr dafür kriegen
pleister glossybox kalla wirklich
perfekt er dann die was cooles ramadam
die cooledeals ausgeschlagen glaube ich
preis leistung ist hier tipptopp und ich
glaube die meisten farben findet auch
jeder super mascara die farben kasten
glaube ich auch lernen also ich bin mal
gespannt ob ich noch dieses jahr in
amazon beauty adventskalender kriege und
ob er ansatzweise damit mithalten kann
obwohl er schon ganz gut war das schon
highlighter einer glasbox setzen uns
schon bei so den fan die haben in verlor
[Musik]
nie wieder krank seien und wer auf den
boden geschmissen hast war
der ist wohl verschwunden schade
ich wusste ja nein und dann kommst du
zurück ins zimmer
ich glaube du musst fragen sondern auch
das nicht gelungen
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen diese
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss
dann tschüssi copski eure mal wanne und
kelly
[Musik]